>> Tucker: GOOGLE COLLECTS
MORE DATA THAN PROBABLY ANY
OTHER COMPANY AND PROBABLY KNOWS
MORE ABOUT YOU THAN YOU DO.
YOU THINK THAT THIS MIGHT RAISE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONCENTRATION OF POWER, BUT FOR
YEARS CONGRESS SEEMS TO HAVE
CARED NOT AT ALL EITHER BECAUSE
THEY WERE IDEOLOGICALLY
PREDISPOSED TO GOOGLE OR IN
THEIR POCKET, MEANWHILE, GOOGLE
BECAME MORE AND MORE POWERFUL,
OMINOUSLY POWERFUL.
DURING A LAME DUCK SESSION,
CONGRESS HAS CALLED THE CEO OF
GOOGLE TO ANSWER SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT DATA
TRANSPARENCY.
WHAT SHOULD CONGRESS ASK HIM
ABOUT?
FOLLOWING THE ISSUE MAY BE MORE
CLOSELY THAN ANY OTHER ATTORNEY,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON PAID WHAT SHOULD BE THE LIST
OF QUESTIONS?
>> THIS IS ONLY A SUBSET OF THE
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ASKING GOOGLE THAT IS THE
SUBJECT OF THE TESTIMONY
TOMORROW.
BUT GOOGLE FOR YEARS AS HE
POINTED OUT HAS BEEN COLLECTING
DATA AND NOT DISCLOSING TO USERS
NUMBER ONE THE EXTENT OF THE
COLLECTION OF THE DATA OR WHAT
THEY ARE DOING WITH THE DATA, WE
HAVE KNOWN OF BREACHES,
INCLUDING TODAY A BREACH OF
52.5 MILLION USERS IN THE
GOOGLE+ FAILED EXPERIMENT IN
SOCIAL MEDIA, IT IS NOT CLEAR
WHEN THAT HAPPEN, GOOGLE IS NOT
IT DISCLOSING PEOPLE WHAT IT
HAPPENED AND WHAT HE WAS HAS
BEEN MADE OF IT, AS I POINT OUT
THEY GET AWAY WITH IT, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A SEAT OF POLITICIANS
IN WASHINGTON EVEN ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE, AND THE
AGENCY’S PAST, IT IS TO EXAMINE
THE ISSUES AND PROTECT
CONSUMERS.
CONSUMERS ARE AT A COMPLETE LOSS
PAID WHAT I EXPECT TO HAPPEN ON
CAPITOL HILL IS THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME POSTURING QUESTIONS
WRITTEN BY STAFFERS AND MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS THAT THEY WILL READ
OUT AND YOU WILL HAVE SOME FOCUS
GROUP TESTED JARGONY
INCOMPREHENSIBLE RESPONSES FROM
IMPEACHING FOLKS TO DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A DANCE, AND EVERYBODY
WILL GO HOME NOT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE ANSWERS WERE AND
PROBABLY NOT DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT, THIS IS A REAL TRAGEDY
AND MISSED OPPORTUNITY, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT A SHAME, I
WILL ASK YOU ANOTHER ELEMENT OF
THE GOOGLE STORY, SEVERAL GOOGLE
EMPLOYEES PLOTTED TO GET RID OF
BREITBART AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION, LABELED THE RESIST,
GOOGLE EMPLOYEES DISCUSSED HOW
THEY COULD USE THE "HATE SPEECH"
AND FAKE NEWS LABELS TO JUSTIFY
CUTTING OFF BREITBART’S AD
REVENUES.
THIS IS KIND OF THE STUFF OF
CONSERVATIVE FEVER DREAMS THAT
GOOGLE WOULD BE ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY IT?
AND WHAT CAN BE DONE?
>> A, AM NOT SURPRISED, GOOGLE
IS DENYING IT, BUT THERE IS
EXTENSIVE EVIDENCE THAT THEY DID
IT.
AND THEY DID IT IN TWO WAYS.
ONE WAY WAS AFTER THE ELECTION
AS HE MENTIONED A NUMBER OF
EXCITABLE LEFT-WING GOOGLE
EXECUTIVES AND EMPLOYEES TRIED
TO SQUEEZE BREITBART AND OTHER
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS INTO THIS
HATE SPEECH CATEGORY.
THEY THEN CONFESSED THAT AFTER A
LOT OF EFFORT THAT WAS REALLY
TOUGH.
SO THEY ALSO DID A TWO PRONGED
APPROACH, AND HAVING THEIR AD
PEOPLE CONTACT CUSTOMERS AND
TELL THEM THAT IT MIGHT BE
DANGEROUS OR A BAD IDEA TO
ADVERTISE OR ALLOW THE ADS TO BE
PLACED ON CONSERVATIVE NEW
WEBSITES LIKE BREITBART AND
OTHERS.
AND POINTED TO SOME OUTSIDE
GROUPS LIKE SLEEPING GIANT THAT
MAKES IT A BUSINESS PRACTICE OF
DEFAMING CONSERVATIVE WRITERS IN
ORGANIZATIONS AND USING THAT AS
A SMEAR.
GOOGLE ALSO DOES THIS AND MANY
OTHER WAYS LIKE THROUGH ITS
YOUTUBE AND CATEGORIES AS
CONTENT AS SENSITIVE, WHICH
AUTOMATICALLY BOTH MAKES IT HARD
TO FIND THE CONTENT ONLINE AND
ALSO STRIPS THAT CONTENT FROM
THE ABILITY TO GAIN ADVERTISING
REVENUE.
SO GOOGLE IS DOING THIS
SYSTEMATICALLY, THEY ARE DOING
IT PURPOSEFULLY.
AND I THINK THAT IT VIOLATES NOT
JUST SOME LAWS INCLUDING DECENCY
ACT, BUT IT VIOLATES STATE LAWS
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH FRAUD AND
TRANSPARENCY ON BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND CONSTITUTION, ABLE
TO GET AWAY WITH THIS, BECAUSE
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO SOME
CONSERVATIVE GROUPS LIKE SEA
PACKET, A LOT OF MONEY TO SHOW
UP, AND
CERTAINLY ON CAPITOL HILL, THEY
GET AWAY WITH IT.
AND WE SEE NOTHING DONE TO
CONTROL THIS DUOPOLY, MONOPOLY
ON ADVERTISING REVENUE.
IT IS VERY DANGEROUS, BECAUSE OF
THE SHAPING OF WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE
IN AMERICA WHO MAINLY GET THEIR
NEWS THROUGH GOOGLE SEE EVERY
DAY.
>> Tucker: LOOKING BACK, THE
CONGRESS ALLOWING GOOGLE TO
BECOME MORE POWERFUL, SUBVERTING
THE DEMOCRACY COMPLETELY, THAT